the jurogan experience what was it like
fighting conor when he wasn't an [ __ ]
was that weird dude you know fighting is
hectic already yeah
you're about to go in there for 25
minutes and you've been training so you
know what's on the line so it's just a
lot of pressure
so uh just it being a little bit more
calm for me
was was smooth sailing man you know
because it's already hectic enough
i say the same thing about the fans like
when i fought at the apex it was nice
you know cause like i said fighting is
crazy so without having guys spilling
beer yelling you're going to die
right you know we're on the way to the
walk isn't it it's relaxing to me
yeah yeah so it's just makes it smooth
sailing
so it's not good for him it's really
better for him to be an [ __ ] yeah be
an [ __ ]
but it seemed so odd it's just like he
just decided that he respected you and
just but he did the same thing with
cowboy i thought like maybe this is him
just maturing and
he's got a few kids now i think he has
one or he does have one on the way
like maybe he's just maturing and he's a
different you know we all change maybe
he's a different person but
yeah could be but i think also
the amount of [ __ ] that he caused
in the khabib fight i mean realizing at
the end of it
what had happened dudes jumped into the
cage and beat his ass
guys were jumping and could be jumped
out of the cage you got to fight with
dylan danis
it's chaos i mean it was so nuts
yeah and then you know what had happened
before that with him throwing the card
at the bus and you know fights got
canceled because broken glass kind of
kiesa got cut i think a couple other
guys got cut with with the glass that
was flying
it's like he had done so much and [ __ ]
up so much throwing energy cans at press
conferences remember oh that's right
yeah that's right yeah but that was kind
of like minor
compared to comparison cutting people
with broken glass and a bus yeah but the
um
the cassidy caused is so much but that
had also been a part of
what sold fights yeah like caught like
the jose aldo fight he
tortured jose aldo for months remember
they did that crazy press conference
where they toured all over the world i
mean ripped the picture yes
stole his belt it's my belt and by the
time they got into the cage jose also
was afraid right
and his i wouldn't know afraid just over
thought
yeah oh you know in his own head in his
own head yeah he seemed
compared to what i what i'd seen from
aldo in the past
he seemed much more nervous much more
aware of the magnitude of the moment
and conor seemed so relaxed and i felt
that same thing though the first time i
fought
conor i felt like that when the bell
rang i was like a deer in the headlights
it's happening here we go all this you
know all that talk and everything
over the months just sat in my head yeah
and uh i just read into it too much
thought too much and i think that's
probably what happened with aldo
that is what [ __ ] talking can do to a
person right it's the art of war man i
mean
yeah fighting is is is mental
you know as much mental as it is
physical i believe well there's so much
mental involved
i mean it's for sure physical but it's
also look it's mental just to get
yourself through training camp
right yeah to cut weight to show up to
do
interview after interview press
conference after press conference you
know
how hard is that to do while you're
getting ready for a fight while you're
cutting
weight doing these interviews and
they're boring ask questions
same question over and over what's
different between uh
this dustin and dustin six years ago in
connor beach like
if i heard that question a thousand
times um it just gets
redundant and it's aggravating you know
before you even sit down and do the
interview you know the
questions you and it's just going
through the motions i just
some are fun though some interviewers
are good and change it up and then it's
a fun
conversation but most of them it's the
same thing how was camp how are you
feeling
yeah what's different between this
dustin but i don't know how much of that
stuff sells a fight either i really
don't
i feel like you should cut it off about
two weeks out i feel like you can get
the interviews in
before and then the last two weeks just
leave the [ __ ] fighters alone
leave them alone right just let them
train only do the big ones like an espn
sports center interview or something
just the big ones
just a quick one cut out all the media
mma media
like how many hours of that [ __ ] do you
have to do in a week
for this conno this last counter one i
was stuck in the hotel
on fight island so it was all mostly
from my computer i would say
over that whole fight week um three
hours maybe
total oh that's not too bad no that's
not too bad yeah
what did you think of conor pulling up
to the fight island in that yacht
that's baller man i was mad i'm like
damn i want a [ __ ] yacht
you do but you don't you know that [ __ ]
that
seems like you have to have so much more
money than the yacht cost
to enjoy the yacht you know what i mean
i mean it looks like a big one
look at a big one but it's like you have
a yacht this is my thought like if you
if you have a yacht
and the yacht is worth whatever a
yacht's worth what does the yacht cost
10 million bucks okay let's say 10
million that one probably more
probably more let's say 20 million bucks
let's say you got a 20 million
yacht for you to not be sweating that
yacht you better have 100 million
right you know you got like how much
does it cost to gas up how much does it
cost
how much does the pilot cost how much
does the captain what
what am i doing for repairs [ __ ]
those big yachts have to have a crew i
think you're year round yeah
all year round all year round yeah so
you're paying a staff salary they live
on it it's their house
you just go and sit in it every now and
then and i heard there's a big docking
fee as well so wherever the boat stays
you're paying a big docking fee so
you're thinking about all that
while you're about to fight that seems
like
more money more problems he's got that
whiskey money man he's all right he does
have that whiskey
that is a different thing i got that
whiskey money yeah whiskey money is a
different thing
i'm building it up man i got the hot
sauce money coming in
i'll pull up on like a bass boat next
time
[Laughter]
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience